ça fait des heures qu ils trépignent
derrière les grilles de buckingham
palace et enfin le voit si le chevalet
avec ce petit mot de la famille royale
il est né à 5h26 nous sommes enchantés
l'heureux papa les mains dans les poches
c'est donc lui le prince harry qui a
préféré faire l' annonce d'abord sur
instagram avant de venir en parler
devant les écuries de windsor suis
vraiment excité et dit-il avant de se
faire plus philosophe ce que vous faites
les femmes c'est au delà de
l'entendement
sa femme depuis un an
meghan markle permet donc à la lignée
royale d'avoir un peu de métissage avec
ses racines africaines
c'est très positif dit cet expert
ça rend la famille plus accessible plus
pertinente plus contemporaine difficile
de passer à côté infos crieur se
chargent de répandre la nouvelle qui
trônent aussi au sommet de la tour
british telecom
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est fantastique ça met du baume au
coeur même si certains le montre un peu
moins femmes expire api que
contrairement à kate et william qui ont
montré leurs enfants quelques heures
après la naissance
aucune image de ce petit qui n'est pas
un prince et qui n'a pas de nom
et dans le jeu du trône il est en
septième place derrière charles williams
et ses trois enfants et harry à partir
de la septième place la vie est plus
facile
pas besoin de l'assentiment de la reine
pour se marier par exemple rendez vous
dans deux jours pour plus de détails ici
mathieu prostré le canada